In this video I'm going to cover the price
earnings to growth ratio, or PEG ratio as
it's sometimes known, and talk about how
it can be used effectively in the
investment process, and illustrate some
arguments as to why we use it in this way,
using a couple of Excel examples.
So this material is basically
supplementary to video 19, drilling from
the top down 2, where we discuss similar
things with the PE ratio.
So what is it? The PEG ratio is just a
valuation multiple that builds upon the
standard PE ratio, and it aims to improve
upon it by accounting for a company's
anticipated growth in earnings.
Now the reason why this can be regarded as
an improvement comes down to financial
theory, which says we can value something
by discounting its future cash flows, and
to anticipate future cash flows we need to
be able to forecast a growth rate, and
that's the principle behind models like
the DCF model.
So the reason why I'm covering the PEG
ratio in this video is that it's becoming
a much more widely used valuation metric,
and it's important that we as retail
traders know how to deal with it
correctly.
So as far as calculating the PEG ratio
goes, it's fairly simple. It's just the PE
ratio divided by the earnings per share
growth.
So for example, if we have a PE ratio of
10 and annual growth in earnings of 20%,
then the PEG ratio is just 10 divided by
20, which equals 0.5.
Now, theoretical finance teaches us that a
stock with a PEG ratio of less than 1 is
undervalued or cheap, and conversely, a
stock with a PEG of over 1 is overvalued
or expensive.
And sometimes you might see analysts in
the market justify their stock
recommendations in this manner, for
example, by putting a buy recommendation
on a stock with a PEG ratio of less than
1.
But this is the wrong way to deal with the
PEG ratio in the investment process, and
it's the same trap that retail investors
often fall into.
So in reality, the PEG ratio is as
misinterpreted as the PE ratio, and all it
actually represents is the price the
market is willing to buy and sell the
company's earnings and earnings growth
potential for.
So just as in the PE ratio, there's no
cheap or expensive, under or overvalued,
and similarly to the PE ratio, the PEG
ratio can stay the same while the stock
price rises or falls.
So if we take an example of that, stock A
is trading at $10 a share and has a
current earnings per share estimate of $1
and growth in earnings per share estimate
of 20%.
So our PEG ratio there is just the PE
ratio divided by the earnings per share
growth, which is 10 over 20, which is 0.5.
Now, we can also figure out last year's
earnings per share by discounting this
year's expected earnings per share
estimate and the expected earnings per
share growth.
So that's simply obtained by taking the
earnings per share $1 divided by the
discount factor of 1.2, which equates to
the 20% EPS growth figure, and that equals
$0.833.
So now, if we imagine that the company
comes out and guides the market down to a
revised lower EPS number of $0.9, then
this effectively changes the EPS growth
rate to 8%, which we can figure out using
last year's EPS number.
So with the EPS number and EPS growth
figure revised down, all that has to
happen for the PEG ratio to remain
constant at 0.5 is for the price to fall
proportionally.
So in this case, the price just needs to
fall to $3.6.
So as long as the stock price falls
proportionally with the earnings and the
earnings growth relative to the previous
year, then the stock can lose almost all
its value, while the PEG ratio actually
remains the same.
So in this case, theoretical finance would
actually tell us to buy this cheap stock
all the way down from $10 to $3.6, and we
would have lost a lot of money doing so.
Now, in reality, the stock price actually
anticipates moves in EPS and EPS growth
numbers in terms of the PEG ratio.
So for stocks with a PEG ratio of less
than 1, they're actually punished by the
market for continually missing EPS and EPS
growth estimates, and therefore, the
market expects them to miss them again and
again.
And it's prepared to sell the stock at a
low valuation because they regard the
company's earnings a low quality.
And in the future, what's actually likely
to happen is that the EPS and EPS growth
numbers will catch up with the stock
price.
And if you argue with this and actually
buy the stock, you're claiming that
essentially you know more than the market
when you don't.
And similarly, with stocks with a PEG
ratio of over 1, they're rewarded by the
market for continually beating EPS and EPS
growth estimates.
So the market expects them to beat them
again and again and is prepared to buy the
stock, this time at a high valuation,
because the earnings and growth are of
high quality.
And again, in the future, it's likely that
the EPS and EPS growth numbers will
actually catch up to the rising stock
price.
And if you argue with that and short the
stock, again, you're claiming that you
know more than the market and quite often
you'll end up being proved wrong with a
hefty loss to your trading account to go
with it.
So the fact that the market is willing to
pay more for quality earnings drives us to
the same conclusion as in video 19, where
we showed that nothing is ever cheap or
expensive.
So we've basically seen that share prices
can go from zero to infinity and vice
versa, while the PEG ratio actually
remains the same.
And so the most important thing to take
away from this video is the understanding
that the PEG ratio is a representation of
the quality of earnings and growth outlook
for a stock.
So next I'm going to go through a couple
of Excel examples to show what can
actually go wrong when the PEG ratio is
used incorrectly according to theoretical
finance.
And while we do that, it will also serve
as a tutorial for how you can conduct PEG
analysis yourself.
Now I'm going to show you how to do some
PEG analysis yourselves and go through a
couple of examples to illustrate what can
go wrong when you use the PEG ratio
incorrectly when you're investing.
So we're going to look at what can happen
when you buy a stock with a PEG ratio of
less than one or sell a stock with a PEG
ratio of greater than one in accordance
with financial theory.
And show that it's actually much better to
think of a PEG ratio as a signal of
quality for a company's earnings and
earnings growth.
And the process we're going to use is
fairly simple.
It's basically just going to look at
historical price data and historical PEG
ratio data for a given stock and see how
they relate to each other over time.
So the first thing we need to do is obtain
the data.
Now in this video, I'm actually going to
skip over how we obtain price data since
we've already covered that in previous
videos using Yahoo Finance.
But what I will do is briefly show you how
to obtain PEG ratio data and import it
into Excel and compare it with your price
data.
So to do that, we just need to go to
Ycharts.com and then in this example, I'm
going to look at the stock Ralph Lauren.
So I'm going to type in RL and select
Ralph Lauren from the drop down menu.
And then to find PEG ratio data, just
select data and from the performance
metric drop down menu, just find PEG ratio
and click on that.
And that gives you the historical PEG
ratio data for the stock that you're
looking at.
And it begins with the date that is last
available for that stock.
Now, unfortunately, in Ycharts, it's
actually not possible to export data
properly in an Excel file unless you pay
for a subscription.
But you can actually get the data in a
much more crude fashion, which is what
we're going to do in this video.
And that simply just involves copying and
pasting the data from the website into
Excel.
And obviously, this takes a little bit
more time than a normal data file would.
So I'm not actually going to go through
the whole example because it's going to
involve about two years of data.
Instead, I'm just going to show you a
couple of pages of how you get this data
into Excel.
And then we're going to use a pre-made
Ralph Lauren spreadsheet ready for the
analysis later in the video.
So it is literally as simple as copying
and pasting.
So if you just select all the data that
you want, including the date and the PEG
ratio from the webpage,
and then within that selection, click
Copy, right-click and copy.
And then I'm going to paste this into this
pre-made Ralph Lauren spreadsheet and just
paste it into a cell in Excel.
That will give you your date column and
your PEG ratio column, and they'll all
line up correctly.
All you need to do is delete the break in
the data set halfway down.
And then you've got a consistent data set.
So then all you need to do is go to the
next page of data, and you can keep going
back as far as you want.
Do this for however many pages of data you
want.
Keep going, copy and paste that in below
your previous data, and delete the break
in the data set.
And then once you've done that and gone
back as far as you want,
you'll end up with something like what
I've got here on the left-hand side in
columns A and B,
with the date and the PEG ratios.
And then all you need to do is go to Yahoo
Finance and obtain the daily closing price
data for all the dates within your date
range.
And make sure they correspond to the
correct ones.
So the easiest way to go about conducting
our analysis, our PEG ratio analysis,
and looking at how it relates to the price
over time, is by making a chart.
So that's what we're going to do first.
We're just going to select all the data,
and then insert a line chart of this data.
And that gives us the line chart of all
the relevant data that we require for our
analysis.
The first problem we've got here is a
scaling problem.
So at the moment, the PEG ratio data is
stuck around a value of 1,
and it's using the same axis as the price
data, which is around 150.
So we're going to create a secondary axis
for the PEG ratio data
by selecting the PEG ratio line and
right-clicking on it and formatting the
data series,
and then adding a secondary axis here.
That gives us a secondary axis, a PEG
ratio axis on the right-hand side.
And the next scaling problem we're going
to resolve is the price data
just hanging around at the top of the
chart,
when actually, in order to sort of
visually interpret it more easily,
we want it to use much more of the chart.
So we're going to change the left-hand
axis, the price axis,
to have a minimum value of something
greater than zero.
So to do that, we left-click the axis,
then right-click,
format axis, and change the minimum fixed
value to, in this case, 100.
So now we can visualize the PEG ratio and
stock prices relationship over time.
So let's have a look at what would happen
if we bought and sold the stock
in accordance with financial theory,
i.e., when the stock is over and
undervalued according to the PEG ratio.
So, remember, with the PEG ratio,
a stock is overvalued when it's above 1
and undervalued when it's below 1.
So we're going to insert a line at a PEG
ratio of 1
so we know that when the PEG ratio goes
below 1 and is above 1.
And I'm just going to format that object
by right-clicking on the line
and changing the line color to black and
making it a bit wider.
So now we can see the date range when the
PEG ratio is less than 1, i.e.
undervalued,
and the range when it's over 1 and
overvalued.
So now what we're going to do is go
through the chart chronologically
and add in buy and sell signals in
accordance with financial theory
by adding lines to the chart, vertical
lines, green and red lines for
green for buy and red for sell.
And we'll do this at the major changes in
the PEG ratio.
So, like this change here from below 1 to
above 1 and here and so on.
And those changes that actually come about
from changes in EPS and EPS growth
estimates.
So, let's start now by, we're going to
start at the very beginning.
So, September 2011, we're going to say
that's a buy signal in accordance with
financial theory
because the PEG ratio is less than 1,
representing undervaluation.
So, we should buy the stock in
anticipation that the stock price will
rise.
I'm just going to make this a bit wider
and green, this line.
Because that's what financial theory
dictates.
Now, the next major change is in, at the
end of December 2011,
where the PEG ratio rises from less than 1
to greater than 1.
So, it's going from undervalued to
overvalued.
And so, that can be regarded as a sell
signal.
And then again, at the end of March 2012,
it goes from above 1 to below 1,
overvaluation to undervaluation.
Remember, these significant changes in the
PEG ratio are down to revisions to a
company's EPS and EPS growth estimates.
So, that is a buy signal because it's
dipping below a PEG ratio of 1.
And the final line we're going to insert
is at the end of June 2012,
where the PEG ratio rises from less than 1
to above 1, representing overvaluation,
and hence is a sell signal.
So, now let's consider what happens to the
stock price after our buy and sell signals
through this chart.
So, September 2011, we've got a buy
signal, but actually the stock price falls
to the next sell signal.
And again, similarly, we then have a sell
signal, but then the stock price is
actually rising to the next buy signal.
And this happens consistently through this
chart.
So, essentially, the stock price is
actually doing the opposite to what
financial theory should dictate.
So, why is this happening?
What is actually happening here?
Starting from the beginning, September
2011, the market is actually selling the
stock in anticipation of EPS and EPS
growth decline.
So, effectively, it's pricing in the
company's revision to EPS and EPS growth
estimates, which then happens here when
the PEG ratio rises from less than 1 to
above 1.
So, the revision is downwards, hence the
stock price is pricing that in before that
happens.
And then, again, the market begins to buy
the stock in anticipation of higher EPS
and EPS growth.
So, they start buying the stock somewhere
around January 2012, in anticipation that
EPS and EPS growth rates will be revised
upwards.
And then, they're actually proved right
come the end of March 2012, where EPS and
EPS growth estimates are revised upwards.
And, hence, the PEG ratio has a fall in
value, and that happens again in the next
segment of the chart.
And then, post-June 2012, we can see a
good example of the market continually
buying the stock and paying for good
quality earnings and growth,
which effectively rewards the company for
anticipated EPS and EPS growth revisions
upwards.
So, now we're going to briefly look at
another example, where it's even more
obvious that the market's willing to pay
for good quality earnings.
And that example is a company called 3M.
So, we're just going to briefly go through
the same analysis, although this one's
much quicker.
We don't need to add in all the lines that
we did in the previous chart.
So, first thing to do, create the chart by
selecting all the data, clicking insert,
insert simple line chart, and we're going
to resolve our scaling problems again.
So, we're going to add a secondary axis
for the PEG ratio data by selecting the
PEG ratio line, right clicking format data
series and adding second axis.
And then, again, our next scaling problem
will get the price line to use a lot more
of the chart by right clicking on the
price axis and changing the minimum fixed
value to 70.
So, in this example, over the whole period
that we're looking at, about a year-long
period, the company is actually being
rewarded through a rising stock price for
anticipated EPS and EPS growth rate
revisions upwards.
And, needless to say, following financial
theory, would actually lose a lot of money
on this stock as well.
So, you can now use this analysis yourself
when generating trade ideas as a
supplementary tool to looking at PE
ratios.
With PE ratios, if we have long ideas,
we're looking for PE's on a premium to the
sector, and for shorts, we're looking for
PE's on a discount to the sector.
And this is because we know that high PE
ratios mean that the market's willing to
pay for high quality earnings, and with
low PE ratios, the market's actually
punishing the stock for low quality
earnings.
And then, we can look for reasons as to
why this is the case.
So, if there's no reason to go against the
market, then it's very clear that you
don't know anything that the market
doesn't know, and you're actually fighting
the trend.
Similarly, you can look for long ideas
with PE ratios above 1 and short ideas
with PE ratios of less than 1, and you'll
see that, as with the PE ratio, the market
will continually reward companies with
higher than sector average EPS growth, and
punish those with lower than sector
average EPS growth.
So, that's all you need to know about PE
ratio analysis.
I hope that you can incorporate this into
your investment framework successfully,
and good luck with your trading.
Good luck with your trading.